a guard of honor at the holy see for
european parliament president martin
schulz making an official visit to pope
francis seven months after he began his
papacy it was a
extraordinary open-minded meeting we
spoke about lampedusa and the question
of a kind of immigration from regions
with civil wars
natural disasters
and hopelessness more than 300 illegal
immigrants mostly from north africa died
last week when their overcrowded vessel
caught fire and sank off lampadusa meps
held a minute silence for the victims
europe must prepare a strategy for
temporary protection and on the other
hand
we must discuss urgently
a system of legal
immigration into the european union
president schultz extended an invitation
to pope francis to address meps
something last seen exactly 25 years ago
in october 1988 when pope john paul ii
visited strasbourg
then it was on to the pontifical
gregorian university in rome for a
public discussion on the fight against
poverty and marginalization